Музыка Musik Danke schön! Vielen Dank! Schaffatize, meine Damen und Herren! Und Florian Will, meine Damen und Herren! Danke schön! Vielen Dank! Danke schön! Hey Leute, was geht? Noch haben wir nichts gemacht, noch ist alles unverdient. Herzlich willkommen in Mannheim, herzlich willkommen in der alten Feuerwache, völlig richtig. Herzlich willkommen zum
Podcast UFO, schön, dass Sie alle da sind. Folge 146 heute Abend hier. Alles ganz normal, bis auf die Tatsache, dass es die erste Folge unserer zweiten Tour ist, die hier erstmals prämiert wird. Ihr seid also das erste Publikum der zweiten Tour. Da filmt schon jemand, da filmt schon jemand und das ist sehr früh.
Sehr früh.
Wir müssen sagen, das ist sehr früh, es ist noch nicht so viel passiert. Wir kommen gerade noch rein, aber filmt euch schon mal. Aber wir haben eine Menge, also da merkt man schon langsam mittlerweile, dass wir in Tour zwei sind, wir haben dieses riesige Stück Stoff gefunden und dachten uns, was machen wir damit? Aber es ist so knitterig, als wären wir bei Tour fünf, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Ja, stimmt schon. Es ist ein bisschen knitterig, Muss man mangeln vielleicht. Hast du doch einen Mangel? Wir hatten einen Mangel zu Hause. Wir haben alles gemangelt. Das hast du? Ich weiß nicht, was eine Mangel ist. Ich auch nicht hundertprozentig. Ein Riesengerät, wo man so Dinge rein... Setzst du dich jetzt schon hin? Das ist schon der Punkt, wo du dich hinsetzt? Du, ich muss mich hinsetzen, tatsächlich. Mangel ist ein schwieriges Thema. Erstmal zurücksetzen, erstmal durchatmen. Das war der gesamte Rahmen meiner Bewegungsfreiheit, tatsächlich. Jetzt muss ich mich erst wieder mich mit Seiten stecken. Warum hast du das schwarze Mikrofon und ich habe dieses RTL Comedy-Comprie-Mikrofon? Stefan hat das Red-Nose-Benefiz. Man ist automatisch lustiger auch. Jeder Gag wird doppelt so gut durch dieses Rode. Wenn es nicht läuft, bei dir gebe ich dir das Mikro, dann läuft es. Dann läuft es von ganz alleine. Wie geht es euch, Mannheim? Alles gut? Yeah! Sehr gut. Es ist die alte Feuerwache. Das hört man auch hier. Wow, diese Akustik in der alten Feuerw gut. Es ist die alte Feuerwache, das hört man auch hier, wow diese akustikende alten Feuerwache.
Es ist die alte Feuerwache, wir lieben ja Mannheim, also wir sind ja wirklich riesen Mannheim-Fan.
Wir sind, Mannheim ist die Stadt der Föhne und Föhne, Föhne kommen aus Mannheim, also selten so gute Föhne wie, also Messer, Solingen sagt man ja, Autos, Ingolstadt, Föhne und? Föhne. Föhne kommen aus Mannheim, also selten so gute Föhne wie Messersolingen, sagt man ja, Autos, Ingolstadt, Föhne, Mannheim. Kennst du ionisierte Föhne oder ionisierende Föhne? Ionen, auch aus Mannheim. Von allen Gegenständen der Welt, in die die Ionentechnologie hätte fliessen können. Man hat sich den Föhnaus ausgesucht. Man hat sich den Föhnaus gesucht. Wir haben jetzt diese Ionen hier, überall diese Drecks-Ionen hier, was machen wir damit?
Und dann hat einer gesagt, Leute, wenn einer Hilfe braucht, dann Föhne.
60 Minuten, den hier ist zu lang. Da muss was passieren.
Ich finde, Föhne sind schon sehr gut.
Du siehst auch so aus, als du gerade aus der Dusche kam.
Ja, ich komme gerade aus der Dusche.
Es ist Sport, es ist Sport für mich.
Wird dieses Handtuch so von einem Stefan zum nächsten überreicht?
Es ist vor allem mein Fitnessstudio-Outfit. So komme ich immer rein und dann erst mal Getränk, erst mal schön in den Stepper und dann erst mal eine halbe Stunde und dann nach Hause. So schnell guckst du dich gar nicht um. Ich gucke mich selten um. Ich habe das Gefühl, Fitnesscenter besteht so 40 Minuten umgucken, 10 Minuten trainieren, 40 Minuten umgucken. Tipp, sei kurzsichtig und setz deine Brille nicht auf. Kein Umgucken, wenig Umgucken. Ich habe eigentlich nur ein Nackentraining gemacht im Fitnesscenter, immer nur so. Einfach nur den die ganze Zeit. Aber ich habe seitdem einen sehr starken Nacken, wahnsinnig starken Nacken, muss man sagen. Also unglaublich. Ich weiß nicht, was ich damit machen soll, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe meine gesamten McFit-Punkte im Nacken gesteckt. Ich weiss nicht, was ich damit machen kann. Das ist wie wenn man sich im Rollenspiel verskillt, wenn man einfach so alles auf Nacken aus Versehen und dann so und dann auf Speichern geklingelt. Es sollte ein Gag sein, aber auf Speichern geklingelt. Fuck! Genau. Ja, das ist eigentlich eine gute Metata. Ganz kurz, wir sind in der Feuerwache, wir sind in der alten Feuerwache. Ist das diese Säulen, sind die das Pendant von dieser Stange? Ist man früher das runtergerutscht? Als die Menschen noch größer waren. Also das war ja wirklich... Früher waren die Menschen größer. Aber auch hier, warum kriegen diese Stangen nur die Feuerwehr, dass man sagt so, wir müssen schnell an einem Ort sein. Aber ist das ein Urban Myth? Oder gibt es diese Stangen wirklich? Nee, die gibt es wirklich. Warum?
Rolltreppen, ähnlich schnell.
Du willst ja schn...
Nee, nee, nee.
Da steht dann immer so ein Trottel im Weg.
Schnelle Rolltreppen?
Links stehen, rechts geht's dir gut, Blende auf acht.
Das weiß niemand, was man da machen muss auf der Rolltreppe.
Dann stehen die alle im Weg.
Aber auch hier von allen die Polizei, Krankenwagen,
alle könnten die Stange vertragen,
aber irgendjemand hat gesagt, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nee, erst mal die Feuerwehr. Das ist unser Ding. Die muss erst mal schnell sein, der Rest ist erst mal scheißegal. Polizei hat sowas nicht. Polizei hat gesagt, nee, Pferde, okay, warum gibt's keine Feuerwehrpferde? Das ist ein Runderpunkt, Pferde haben dann wieder nur die Feuerwehr, nur die Polizei. Das Nachdenke-Moment so, hm, weiss das Pferd, dass es in der Polizei ist?
Oder denkt es sich nur die ganze Zeit, warum reiten nur die grünen Menschen auf?
Es weiss, glaube ich, dass es in der Polizei ist, wenn man ihr dieses Blaulicht aussetzt.
Dann sagt es, was ist los?
Ich glaube, da merkt es, was falsch ist.
Fun Fact.
Ich habe einen Fun Fact rausgesucht in Mannheim, einfach weil ich gut bei euch ankommen möchte.
Ich bin sehr unsicher.
Und deswegen möchte ich eure Anerkennung und die hoffe ich mir durch folgenden Funfact zu ergattern. Und zwar die Premiere von Schillers Die Räuber mal in Mannheim. Den ganzen Tag redet er davon. Und darauf kam gar keine Reaktion, also wirklich nichts, gar nichts. Also er läuft schon die ganze Nacht mit diesem Reklamheft rum. Man muss sagen, die sind ja auch nicht aus scheißgelb. Die sind in dieser Signalfarbe, damit alle sehen, dass man gerade ein Reklamheft liest. Das war echt enttäuschend gerade. Ich dachte, das ist wie wenn du, wahrscheinlich müssen sich auch Leute fühlen, die ihr gesamtes Leben lang für ein Waschbrettbrauch trainieren. Und dann irgendwann mal sich ausziehen und alle so so und dann denkst du dir, dafür war ich
vierhundert Stunden im McFit. Ja, habe ich schon mal auf Instagram gesehen, dass du diesen, es ist ja auch keine
Überraschung mehr heutzutage, es ist ja nicht am Strand, dass man diesen Reveal-Moment hat, das ja vorher schon
mindestens auf Instagram hätte ich ein paar Mal revealed. Ja, ich hätte ein paar Mal den Vorhang gelüftet, hätte ich
einen Waschbett braucht, wüsstet ihr es. Ich glaube, ich wäre viel zu ungeduldig, ich würde mich schon nach Woche eins revealen und dann sagen, ja. Ist das der erste Hubbel, ich weiß es nicht, was mit Foto machen. Ey, zu dem Waschberg braucht, man weiß es nicht. Kommen alle sechs simultan raus? Also ist es wie bei Schäferhunde haben ja, wissen ja viele nicht, als Welpen haben die ja Ohren, die nach unten gehen. Und an einem Tag haben die einfach den Stichtag. In den Kopf rein, oder was? Ne, ne, die hängen so runter, wie bei Dackeln, glaube ich. Und an irgendeinem Tag ist einfach der Stichtag und dann bleiben die einfach oben. Ja? Ja, genau. Und ich glaube, so ist es auch mit dem Waschbeilbau, dass du erst nichts hast und irgendwann alle sechs simultan. Es ist so wie Dick da, so erst der eine und dann musst du mehr trainieren und dann drei und dann hast du keinen Bock mehr. Und dann ist die Batterie leer, dann wirkt er sich den Speicherstand nicht mehr und so weiter. Geil. Und so weiter. Ihr kennt das alles, ihr kennt das alles. Also die Räuber. Die Räuber von Schiller, tolles, tolles Werk, habe ich in der Schule aufgeführt tatsächlich. Meine erste Schauspielerin... Wer warst du? Warst du ein Räuber? Nein. Dann kann ich dir jetzt nicht mehr folgen. Warte, warte, ich war ein Statist und tatsächlich, und es war folgendermaßen, es hat sich alles abgespielt auf der Bühne und als Statist warst du, glaube ich, das gesamte Stück zu sehen, so die Räuber, die halt hinten geflätzt haben und du überlegst dir irgendwann, was kann ich denn machen? Du denkst ja, okay, er ist Statist bei die Räuber, dann Quentin Tarantino, wie kann ich diesen Schritt beschleunigen und denkst dann immer so, wie kann ich jetzt meine Emotionen ausdrücken? Und wo ist die Kamera? Und alles, was ich gemacht habe, war das gesamte Stück lang wirklich konstant war. Zu dem anderen Räuber neben mir. Aufeinchen vor allem. Aber wirklich wie so ein GTA-Charakter, den man so wirklich liebevoll mit dem Auto ummessert, einfach so. Im Loop. Die ganze Zeit im Loop. Aber man fragt sich, wenn sich dein Kollege Borentin den gleichen Move ausgedacht hat, noch die ganze Zeit den macht und du so während der Aufführung bei der Premiere denkst, fuck, nach dem gleichen Move. Was mache ich jetzt? Ja, das war unglaublich. Und in der Kritik, und das ist ja immer das schönste, Schülertheater ist ja Drama, Drama, Drama, ich weiss ja, was hinter den Kulissen Drama. Und vor allem, es gibt ja niemanden, der das Drama irgendwie auflöst. So, weißt du, dann weiss man, man denkt sich, ah, wir sind viel besser als Besetzung zwei aus der Inklusionsgruppe, so, wir sind viel besser. Und das Einzige, was so ein bisschen in die Richtung geht eines Endes dieses Drama, ist, wenn der Neureutlinger Anzeiger seine Zweispaltenkritik von dem Theaterstück der Schüler postet, wollte ich gerade sagen. Verrückte Medienbild. Wie schnell sich das verändert, unglaublich. Sie schreiben das bei Hand noch. Da war es dann tatsächlich auch so, die haben dann tatsächlich die Kritik geschrieben und natürlich der ganze Theaterraum, alles rum und dann so, ja, hier Amalia war fantastisch gespielt von der grossartigen Hanna und hier der Räuber. Nur die Statisten wirkten etwas starre. Das kann nicht sein. Und das wirklich die einzige negative Erwähnung war. Und deine Reaktion war. Ja genau, wahrscheinlich. Die einzige negative Erwähnung galt den Statisten. Es gibt in jedem Film diesen einen Statisten, der einfach immer in die Kamera guckt. Das sind die Schauspieler. Das fällt einem auf und vor allem, ich weiß nicht, das hast du mir doch mal gezeigt, mein Egemann. Nee, warum lacht ihr? Die gucken nicht in die Kamera. Der Gag hat keinen Sinn ergeben. Ich gucke dich an, weil ich gerade die Lichtscheinwerfer auf dich zeigt genau. Aber der Einzelner ist fortbekommen. Da ist auch noch jemand, da ist jemand mit der Kappe. Der hat die Vorstellung die Quests ab, bei diesen vier Leuten einfach die ganze Zeit. Man muss zu denen gehen, aber erst wenn man diesen gelben Kreis betritt, dann geht es los. Die Cutscene. Du kannst dich gleichzeitig die Gamer und die Fitnessfreaks abholen. Stefan, du musst dich auf eine Figur einigen, das geht nicht. Ich habe zwei Wochen darüber nachgedacht, wie kann ich breiter werden, wie kann ich breiter werden. Was wollen wir sagen? Statisten. Statisten gucken häufig in die Kamera und dann ist es aufgefallen, bei einem Film, ich weiß nicht genau wie der heißt, aber da gibt es diese grosse, ich glaube mit Owen Wilson ist der, wo der am Ende in so einem Showdown, er hat überlebt, er hat es irgendwie geschafft, rettet sich in diesen Helikopter und daneben
haben die einfach einen Statisten gesetzt, der den
in Empfang nimmt und er guckt die ganze Zeit in die Kamera.
Und dem hat man gesagt,
guckt glücklich irgendwie und er grinst die ganze Zeit
in die Kamera mit dieser hochdramatischen Szene.
Er umwitzelt, dass du gerade überlebt,
kommt in den Helikopter
und er starrt die ganze Zeit in die Kamera.
Weil wo soll er auch sonst hingucken?
Toll, das ist ganz toll. Achtet auf die Statisten.
Ey, Statisten sind nicht das Wichtigste.
Aber so ist es... Background-Artists,
Vielen Dank. Und er starrt die ganze Zeit in die Kamera, weil wo soll er auch sonst hingucken? Toll, das ist ganz toll. Achtet auf die Statisten. Statisten ist nicht das Wichtigste, aber so ist es... Background-Artists, sagt man in Amerika. Ja? Nee, England, glaube ich. In Amerika sind es Extras und hier sind es Komparsen oder Statisten. Background-Artists, für die sind das Künstler. Für die warst du ein Künstler. Du, nichts ist wirklich schwieriger als peinliches Schweigen zu ertragen. Weil oft ist ja dann so, dann heißt es dann so, man machte Party-Szene, wir hatten auch bei guter Arbeit mal einen Sketch, wo ein Party war, und da war es dann so, im Hintergrund standen dann ganz viele Leute, die sich unterhalten mussten, die sich aber natürlich nicht echt unterhalten durften, weil sonst hört man die ja. Das heißt, die mussten wirklich vier Stunden lang am Stück wirklich so ... Die ganze Zeit ich konstant und plötzlich ist alles was du machst und plötzlich ist auch alles unnatürlich was du machst wirklich wenn du dich so beobachtest fühlst es ist egal was du machst unnatürlich egal was du machst.
Aber apropos körperliche Leistungsfähigkeit. Ich finde das gut mit den Muskeln, die eines Tages kommen, weil man sagt ja auch, und das hat mich immer fasziniert, dass es immer so hieß, der Mensch benutzt nur acht Prozent seiner Leistungskraft oder irgendeine Zahl. Als ob ihr euch die Zahl merken würdet, ihr merkt euch nur das drumherum.
Und so die Zahl und dann heisst es immer so, ein bisschen was, also ein bisschen Kraft reserviert der Körper immer noch für Extremsituationen. So, nochmal so eine Schippe, so wenn dann der Tiger um die Ecke kommt, dann bist du plötzlich früher. Wie unsportlich muss man sein, bis das Fitnessstudium eine Extremsituation ist? Extremsituation, das ist die Frage, was der Körper als Extremsituation ist. Also diese fünf Kilo-Hanteln, ey, ohne Scheiss. Ja, da gibt es dann immer so, dann fällt die Familie über die Klippe und plötzlich greift die Mutter und kann dann plötzlich wahnsinnig viel Gewicht ziehen, weil sie die Familie über die Klippe zieht. Kann wahnsinnig gut in Bizeps trainieren, weil sie aber so eine Familie da dran hat, da hat man schon mal die Chance. Ja. Warum gibt es solche Fitnessstudios eigentlich nicht, die einen so Extremssituation bringen? Und hier ist die Familie und oh nein, sie fällt in diesen Pool. Oh nein, die Klippe. Lauf schnell, Rücken. Aus dem Rücken heben. Was ist die Klippe? Finde ich eigentlich auch gut. Und ich glaube, das ist ja eine Frage, wie lange ist das noch so im Menschen? Die Evolution führt ein Jahr weiter und es ist ja nicht mehr notwendig. Heute gibt es ja keine Extremsituation mehr, heute stört das ja eher, dass wenn dann irgendwie der Bus, du den Bus nicht bemerkst und plötzlich bist du stark und klug und das hilft dir nicht. Ich glaube nämlich auch, dass ich der erste Mensch bin, der das nicht mehr hat. Und zwar, der es andersrum macht, der also nicht immer 70% ist und in Extremsituationen 100%. Ich bin immer 100%, aber in Extremsituationen 70%. Also wenn der Tiger kommt, ich bin der Erste, der stirbt, ich bin der Erste, der nicht mehr rechnen kann, der einfach alles falsch macht. Und ich war letztens im Urlaub, ich war im Urlaub unterwegs, und ich war unterwegs und ich laufe so Gleise entlang, auf Gleisen, so, ich laufe auf Gleisen entlang, die Gleise entlang und höre Musik mit meinem Noise-Cancelling-Kopfhörer auf Gleisen. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Und man denkt sich, das ist wie der Anfang von so einer Folge, wo am Ende ganz viel Blut ist, und man weiss genau, hm, ich bin nicht der Notarzt in der Folge, ich bin der andere, ich bin der dumme Statist, der wo in dem Krankenhaus liegt.
In gewisser Weise ein Spoiler, dass du hier gerade stehst für diese Geschichte.
Stimmt, vergesst das mal, ignoriert das mal. Und ich stehe auf jeden Fall auf diesen Gleisen und dann irgendwann denke ich mir so, Moment mal, ach ja Gott, der Podcast, den ich gerade höre, den mag ich nicht mehr. Das Podcast-Ufo. Ich finde, der ist seit sieben Folgen nicht mehr besser geworden. Ich höre auf, ich höre einen anderen. Und dann stehe ich also auf diesen Gleisen, Noise-Canceling, und swipe so durch und gucke und bin so total vertieft in mein Handy. Und wie gesagt, Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer, ich weiß nicht, was los ist. Auf Gleisen stehe ich da, scroll, scroll, scroll, plötzlich links von mir, raschelt der Busch, irgendwas schnellt auf mich zu, ich kann gar nicht gucken, gucke nur noch unten, sehe eine riesige schwarze Schlange, wie sie direkt zwischen meinen Beinen durchweselt, mir mal so einen mitgibt, so einen Schlag gegen Unterschenkel und slither dann so nach rechts weg.
Ich schaue nach rechts, schaue die Schlange, sehe die Schlange, wie sie ins Unterholz flüchtet, Adrenalin.
Und wie sie sagt, da kommt ein fucking Zug, Alter.
Adrenalin pumpt ihn mir hoch und ich denke mir, was macht ein Aal an Land? Das war mein erster Gedanke. Das war alles, wozu mein ach so kluges Extremsituation-Gehirn in der Lage war, war, was macht ein Aal an Land? Das passt doch überhaupt doch überhaupt nicht zusammen. Auch gut, was macht ein Aal an Land nach, warum gehe ich auf Gleisen und kommen. Ja, egal, egal. Dann habe ich ihn zugetroffen. Aber davor war auf jeden Fall, also das war, wo ich mir dachte, wie, das ist jetzt das Erste, was mein Gehirn abarbeiten muss, erst mal die Aal-Theorie. Ja, ich kenne das auch, ich war mal in der U-Bahn und dann ist mir neben mir, da hat die U-Bahn so stark gebremst, dass die Oma, die neben mir war, weggeslidet ist. Sie hatte nicht genug Kraft in ihren Oberschenkeln um diesen Stoss, auch weil ich wahrscheinlich massiv irgendwie, und dann ist die Oma halt so runtergeslidet von dieser Bank und lag dann da und dann so. Ja genau, und dann reagier mal schnell, dann reagier mal so schnell, dass der ganze Zug
nicht sofort sagt, kannst du bitte der oma aufhelfen weil ich war natürlich an der reihe so ich war im ich war im direkten im epizentrum des der ganze zug guckt dahin halt so da war ich problem ist aber ich hatte kopfhörer im ohr so und ich bin auch so ein typ ich mache die musik leiser wenn ich rückwärts einfahr ich kann nur eine mach auch die Musik aus, wenn ich der Oma hochhelfen will, okay? So, dann hab ich mich aber schon verfriemelt irgendwie mit meinem Rucksack und mit diesem, da war noch diese Kabelzeit an den Kopfhörern. Hab mich dann so verfriemelt und dann... Eine Anekdote von 2009, by the way. Richtig. Aber trotzdem kamen halt Leute an und haben mich halt angeschissen, wie ich dieser Oma nicht so schnell helfen konnte. Und natürlich hab ich sofort den Arm da gehabt und dann hab ich das mit dem Kopfhörer gemacht. Aber ich konnte halt nicht so schnell helfen, weil ich wollte erstmal hören, geht's dir gut und so weiter. Aber ich habe nicht, augenscheinlich nicht so richtig gehandelt, wie ich es der Zug von mir erwartet hätte. Und der hat mich richtig rausgeekelt dann, der war richtig sauer, der Zug, dass ich ihr nicht sofort geholfen habe. Das war wirklich nur ungefähr fünf Sekunden vergangen. Aber der Zug kam dann nicht mit klar. Aber eigentlich, ich denke mir mal so, weil so... Das war schlimm, das war traumatisierend.
Bei so Rettungssituationen, jetzt mal konterintuitiv gedacht, du willst immer die erste Person am Tatort sein, weil... Ja, weil du mit einem scheiß fucking Tweet ankommst, um dir den Namen auszudenken für die... Wow, wäre Oh-911 nicht besser gewesen als Nine-Eleven.
Wow, ich war der Erste, der es gesehen hat.
Ja, ist ein anderes Thema. Was ich meine, du willst als Erster bei der toten Oma sein, weil die erste Person kann selbst entscheiden. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss etwas klarstellen bei meiner letzten Anregelte. Sie hat überlebt. Lest mal nicht die Zeitung morgen, wenn es geht. Was ich nur sagen möchte, du willst der Erste bei der toten Oma sein, weil der Erste kann entscheiden, welche Aufgabe er in der Rettung der Oma spielen möchte. Oder er kann direkt diesen Move machen. Ja genau. Und er wird so begraben und lebt und du, ja Leute, was soll das denn eigentlich sein? Und ein Adam. Sorry. Und man kann Dismove machen. Genau. Aber Brille ab, ne? Brille ab? Weiss ich nicht. Und dann wieder Brille aufsetzen? Das ist sehr gut. Sie braucht die Brille wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Braucht jemand eine Brille mit der Stärke, kann man fragen. Sie braucht auch das Portemonnaie, kann man tennishell sofort raus. Wovor braucht sie noch Geld in ihrem Leben? Ja, was mit Kontaktlinsen muss man die dann, also wie soll das gehen? Was machen sie da? Was ich meine ist, du willst die erste Person sein, weil du, also zum Beispiel, angenommen Oma, so, dann laufe ich, aha, clever, zu den Füssen und sag, hier hilf mir mal. Und dann muss man immer, Oberkörper ist immer schwierig, du weißt nicht, wo ist da der Schwerpunkt, was ist dahin. Du willst immer an den Füssen sein. Warum willst du die bewegen?
Nachher hat es irgendwie einen Gnickbruch oder sowas und du verrutscht es aus Versehen und dann hörst du so ein K. Ja, aber nicht an den Füssen. An den Füssen hat noch nie jemand was falsch gemacht und selbst, oh, Knöchel gebrochen, ja, waren sie vielleicht schon davor, vielleicht schon in Stadiengrad gebrochen, weiß man nicht. Vielleicht, und oben kannst du viel mehr Schaden anrichten und oben hast du dieses ganze Augen auf, Augen zu, noch mal einmal blinzeln lassen, man weiss es nicht genau. Warum macht man denn die Augen zu? Weil sie, warum, sie schläft ja nicht. Es hat sowas von, ne, sie schläft nur. Weil es gruselig aussieht, oder, wenn es am Sarg, dann noch mal, wenn das noch mal aufgeb, die Leiche, und dann kommen nochmal die Enkel und gucken sich nochmal an, dann soll die Oma schlafen, oder was ist die... Weiss jemand, was die Idee dahinter ist? Es ist eigentlich besser, wenn die Augen offen sind, weil man dann weiss, dass sie tot ist und eben nicht schläft. Alles an ihr sagt, gut, der Sarg sagt auch, sie ist tot. Gut, gut, ja, aber wenn du die Augen zumachst, machst du, ich lass mal offen, ob sie vielleicht nicht nur schläft. Das stimmt, das ist Quatsch. Eigentlich müsste man so das Genick brechen, so den Kopf 180 Grad drehen, dass jeder weiß, so, da geht gar nichts mehr. Ja, ist auch so, wenn man jetzt so einen Fisch angelt und so, man will sicher sein, der ist tot, dann haut man den halt so ein paar Mal irgendwie auf so einen Amboss oder so. Okay, also du kannst nicht die Gamer, die Fitness und die Fischer auch noch, das geht nicht. Aber du haust ihn ja auch ein paar Mal, damit du sicher bist. Aber haust du den Fisch oder mit dem Fisch? Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Man haut nicht mit dem Fisch. Ich habe mir nur von einem Jäger zeigen lassen, dass man eine Gans ganz einfach töten kann. Mit so einer ganz schnellen Geste. Aber wenn man einen weichen Körper teilt, ist der hier. Ne, das ist der Schnabel. Oder es ist der Avala-Kedabo. Es ist der Avala-Kedabo, aber du hältst den Schnabel fest und dann machst du den. Und schon ist ein Tier tot, wo man auch sagt, warum hat es bis jetzt überlebt? Wenn das die Geste ist, wie du eine Spez hier auslöschen kannst, so warum gibt es dann Gänse noch? Ich bin das wieder Team Ente, das ist es. Du greifst ihn am Schnabel und machst so. Ja, da musst du aufpassen, da gibt's Lehrgänge, da gibt's VHS-Schulen, da machst du... VHS-Schulen, Volkshochschulen-Schulen. Ich find's aber auch gut, dass Stefan zu einem Jäger geht und sagt, ich will jagen und der Jäger sagt, okay, wir holen mal eine Gans, okay? Schritt eins. Erst einmal kannst du töten, traust du dich zu töten. Jäg mal die Gans, jäg, jag, ich jäge. Ich jage, du jagst, er, sie, es jagt, wir jagen, sie jagen, sie jagen. Guten Abend Mannheim, hey! Und jetzt beginnt die Show. Es ist voll einigermaßen, man kann das Publikum nicht sehen, weil wir angestrahlt werden, aber es ist relativ voll, weil die meisten haben noch geschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die meisten waren, aber sehr viele haben geschrieben, dass sie es noch nicht schaffen, pünktlich wegen des Wetters. Deswegen lassen wir die Tür offen, das heißt, jeder, der zu spät kommt, kann nachher rein. Und deswegen beginnt er auch gleich erst. Jede random Person, die draußen vorbeiläuft, kann auch reingehen und denkt sich, der Stefan Tietze trinkt einen Schluck Wasser, das muss ich sehen. Er macht einen Scherz, aber hinter der Bühne hat jemand gesagt, wir können doch die Tür offen lassen, damit die noch reinkommen und er hat gesagt, ja, aber nicht Fremde, oder? Jetzt kannst du alles behaupten, was ich gesagt habe. Das stimmt. Aber auch zum Thema Arschloch sein, auch da habe ich eine Lektion gelernt. Im selben Urlaub, unglaublich unglaublich aufregende Dinge sind passiert, ich laufe durch die Strasse, wie sagt man? Wir sind bei Strasse, Baby Steps. Die Fußgängerstrasse, wie sagt man? Gehweg. Fussweg. Bürgersteig. Kommt ein Auto entgegen, jemand schön aus dem Beifahrerfenster, Hand raus, Mittelfinger, mir entgegen. Aber so den mitgezogenen, so den hier, so richtig schön. Mit deinem Deutschlandhut und deiner Swastika-Jacke rum. Und dann steht man da und denkt, ich brauche konkreteres Feedback, ich brauche detailliertere Maßnahmen. Aber dafür, dass es strafbar war, ist man nicht beleidigt, oder? Also man sagt nicht, this ruined my day.
Ja, man sagt eher, was habe ich falsch gemacht? Und man guckt so an sich runter, modische kurze Hose, gute Arbeit Originals Shirt, was auf der Sprache in dem Land, in dem du warst, heisst. Kann auch sein, oder einfach jemand, der einfach die Sketche nicht mochte. Ich weiss es nicht genau. Und dann wird man noch so, was genau ist ein Problem? Man weiss es nicht. Ich weiss es bis heute nicht genau, was ich falsch gemacht habe. Rufst du im Doppler-Effekt? Klar. Was genau ist ein Problem? Vielleicht nicht star, dass er dich nicht mehr gehört hat. Ding, ding, ding. Das kann sein. Das kann sein. Warum bist du so oft im Urlaub? Ich war jetzt einmal im Urlaub, ich war unterwegs, habe ein bisschen entspannt. Warst du auch so am Strand gelegen und so, auf so einem Liegestuhl schön den Bauch aushängen lassen, schön was gelesen, die Räuber gelesen? Nochmal einfach die Räuber lesen, es ist einfach wunderschön, es ist toll. Tatsächlich bei FM, um nochmal auf euer Lieblingsthema Shakespeare zurückzukommen, Shakespeare, was man ja, was viele nicht wissen, ist wahnsinnig schlecht überliefert. Diese ganzen Texte, die man da so lesen kann, sind hauptsächlich Quatsch. Vor allem wurden die, und das habe ich mal gelesen, auch überliefert, ohne dass man gesehen hat, welche Figur den Satz sagt. Also da steht nur Satz, Satz, Satz, Satz, Satz, aber nicht wer. Und dann muss man überlegen, ja, der vielleicht oder der. Das heißt, es könnte alles komplett unterschiedlich sein. Also wenn ihr heute Abend noch mal schöne Othello euch reingebt, denkt immer dran, vielleicht den coolen One-Liner hat vielleicht gar nicht Othello gesagt, sondern eine Figur, die man gar nicht kennt. Das war die Shakespeare-Stelle an der Stelle normaler.
Da müssen wir durch. Es ist immer ein Downer jeden Abend, aber es ist okay.
Man kommt ja durch.
Ich denke bei Othello immer noch zuerst an den Mobilfunkhersteller.
Das sagt viel über uns aus.
Aber wir müssen ein bisschen was für die Bildung
tun, denn heute ist die Mannheimer
Morgenpost da.
Es ist tatsächlich so.
Man muss es sagen. Wir wussten davon nicht, wo auch immer Sie sitzen, werter Journalist, um ihrem Medium beim Sterben zuzugucken. Wo auch immer Sie sitzen, wir kennen Shakespeare. Wir haben schon Shakespeare gesagt, wir haben schon Schiller gesagt. Ich habe sogar schon eine Anekdote zur Lokalzeitung gebracht. Das ist völlig wichtig. Ich gebe mir wirklich Mühe. Wir wissen ja auch viel über Mannheim. Wir lieben Mannheim, diese Quadrate. Aber ich meine... Quadrate sind toll. Wo sind die Leute von A3? Haha! Niemand aus A3. Läufe auf A6! Da sind die Bösen. Aber ohne Scheiss, hat mal jemand so einen Real-Life-Schach hier gespielt eigentlich? Wo man dann meinetwegen, wenn man es mit einem Kumpel macht, kann man so ein Foto machen, wie man gerade läuft, Läufer, von A3, und dann läuft man meinetwegen mit Runtastic von A3 nach E4. Und dann sagt man so, jetzt bist du dran. Und dann muss der andere so ein Turm-Emoji schicken von dem, wo er gerade ist. Ich glaube, das macht für zwei Minuten sehr viel Spaß. Und dann muss man irgendwann sagen, oh fuck, er hat schon wieder gespielt, wir müssen nach E5 fahren. Ich glaube, man ist an der ersten Etappe schon gescheitert, an diesem Auf-dem-Boden-Flächen-Schach. Wir haben den ganzen Leben noch nie gesehen, dass da jemand dran spielt, geschweige denn, wo man die Figur her haben soll. Also dass man einfach sagt, Moment mal, das trifft sich ja sehr, sehr gut, meine Damen, schnell, schnell, Anträger, so einer riesigen hölzernen Dame unter dem Arm. Moment, wenn ich jetzt noch 16 andere Leute, 15, wo wir gerade beim Schach sind, das ist kurz die Gedankenreihe Schach, Zauberschach, Harry Potter. Harry Potter beim Zauberschach, warum bleibt Ron am Ende, warum bleibt er so Angst davor, dass er geht ja dann, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr noch an Bord seid, aber er geht ja irgendwann auf den Springer und opfert sich. Und das ist so eine riesen tragische Szene. Und ich als Kind denke mir, ja, du spielst halt gerade Schach. So, dann kommt diese grosse Dame und schlägt den Springer von ihm. Und er bleibt bewusstlos da liegen und alle reagieren, als wäre genau das passiert, was sie gerade erwartet hätten. Warum? Er fällt zwei Meter tief. Diese gesamte Szene ergibt von vorne bis hin überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Also wirklich gar keinen Sinn. Verstehe ich nicht. Warum man auch Schach spielen muss, das Spiel, das jeder kennt, wo jeder einfach die ganzen Figuren im Rucksack hat. Einmal tatsächlich war ich im Kochunterricht und habe mich versteckt vor der Lehrerin. Einen Snickers reingehauen. Heute machen wir Salat. Okay, okay. und habe mich versteckt unter der Treppe, die Treppe in Stock, ja das war im zweiten Untergeschoss, war sogar kochen, die Treppe zu im ersten Untergeschoss. Zaubertränke. Verstecke mich unter der Treppe und finde einen riesigen Sack Plastik mit diesen grossen Schachfiguren drin. Irgendwo müssen sie sein. Hier sind sie! Hier sind die Schachfiguren. Hier sind sie, wenn man irgendwo am Tim-Dorfer-Strand Schach spielen will. Muss man hier hin. Aber unglaublich. Also ich weiß welche. Wenn ihr Bock habt, einfach mal grosses Schach zu spielen. Ja, macht das mal hier. Macht mal so einen Trend. Mannheim-Schach. Warum spielt man nicht immer Sportarten in ganz gross einfach? So Riesen-Bowling einfach, wo man einfach so eine riesige Bowlingkugel hat oder die Kegel muss man selber mitbringen, die Kugel liegt im Marktplatz. Aber hat Kegeln und Bowling, hat das eine Herkunft oder sind zwei Leute auf eine ähnliche Idee gekommen? Ich glaube, das ist ein Urheberrechtsstreiter, einfach ganz, ganz weites Kreisgeschlag. Puma und Adidas, zwei verfeinerte Brüder wahrscheinlich. Ja, das stimmt schon. Kegeln ist auch nicht so cool. Bowling hat mehr Blinklichter. Aber auch bei Polo denke ich mir immer wieder, warum gerade die Sportart auf dem Pferd? Also warum hört man da auf? Warum nicht einfach nochmal alle Sportarten nochmal auf dem Pferd? Einfach zu sagen, Billard auf dem Pferd. Einfach nochmal zu sagen, wie wie so ein Ritter mit seiner Lanze im Anschlag am Boning-Billardtisch an, zack, das wäre ein Anblick. Da würde ich auch die Olympischen Spiele noch mal gucken. Wenn man das einführen würde, so einfach so, okay, wir wissen, dass wir uncool sind, kann man jetzt auch mal zugeben nach siebenhundert Jahren, jetzt einfach noch mal alles auf Pferd. Und alles, was vorher auf Pferd war, auf Esel. So, und dann, dann noch mal die Quoten zählen. Dann bin ich dabei. Weisst du, warum die gerade nicht so gelacht haben? Ich fand das sehr lustig, was du gesagt hast. Die haben gerade nicht so gelacht, weil du das schon mal erzählt hast. Und das ist nichts gegen dich, sondern gegen euch. Wenn die Beatles noch mal Hey Jude spielen, okay, dann sagt niemand dem Publikum, ja, das habt ihr schon mal gespielt, sondern man singt mit. Ich habe mir gewünscht, dass ihr das mitsingt.
Mitsprecht einfach, eins zu eins.
Warum macht man es nicht noch mal auf einem Film?
Ich bin gedanklich noch bei Othello, weil das ist ja in England gespielt worden.
Und warum nimmt man einen Namen, der so nah ist an Hello?
Also warum macht man das? Ist das nicht irritiert, das total? Scheiße, unkreativ ist es.
Oder ist das der Gag, dann sagt man so Hello Othello und alle l, ding, ah, das ist das Danke-Anke-Prinzip, ne? Ja, das stimmt. Oh, slow clap. Das Handtuch macht dann unsympathisch, oder? Ich mach's dann. Das liegt am Handtuch. Alte Feuerwache, wir dürfen nicht gleichzeitig trinken oder Handtuch weglegen, das hatten wir abgesprochen. So, dankeschön, dankeschön. Ich finde einfach unser Poster so geil da hinten. Dieses riesige Ding, und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, das ist Version drei, nach einmal das Podcast Ugo, mussten wir wegwerfen. Version zwei, Gästliste Geisterbahn, ganz was schief gelaufen. Ja, wissen wir auch nicht, haben wir gespendet an die Caritas, gucken was die damit machen.
Da kannst du ja schön drei Tischtücher. Ich wollte eine Couch spenden an die Caritas, haben die nicht angenommen, hatten die kein Interesse daran. Wäre zu alt, würde niemand kaufen.
Moment, das Wendt für die Kinder oder was? Ja für Kinder zum drauf rumhüpfen oder Wintermäntel draus machen, ich weiß nicht. Diese Sprungfehler kann man bestimmt für lustige Schuhe benutzen. Hat niemand was angenommen. Ich glaube, dir fehlt so ein bisschen, dass man mal drüber nachdenkt, was man da alles mit machen kann. So eine Couch sind ja unendliche Möglichkeiten. Ist ja nicht nur eine Couch. Sprungschuhe? Das wäre mein zweiter Gedanke gewesen. Das ist deine Idee. Oh, tut mir leid, dass du Krebs hast und leider beide Eltern tot, aber hier sind Sprungschuhe.
Okay.
Ist was anderes einfach direkt.
Kann ich schon verstehen.
Ist schon gut.
Samuel Koch hatte doch Sprungschuhe.
Die waren lustig bis zu dem Moment. Die waren cool.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe es damals live gesehen und ich dachte mir, geile Schuhe, geile Schuhe, holy shit.
Und eine gesamte Industrie und sämtliche Sprungschuhvereine der Welt.
Fuck! Ja, scheiße. Damn it. Ja, shit hier.
Wütend nach Hause.
Auch so ein dramatischer Aufgabe. mich seht ihr nie wieder das funktioniert nicht
aber da muss ich immer daran denken wie wir haben ein Büro bezogen das recht neu war und in das
wurden Türen eingebaut die ein bisschen zu leicht waren was dazu geführt hat dass man jede Tür zu
kräftig zugeschlagen hat so dass man jede Tür immer zugeschlagen hat. Schauen, mach's gut, bis später. Wamm! Ich fand einen super Tag, geiler Dreh, bis morgen Leute, bam! Und einfach alles so, what, was hat er denn? Es war immer ein passiv-aggressiver Abgang, beziehungsweise aggressiv-aggressiver Abgang. Das sind die Besten. Ich dachte jetzt, du gehst weiter auf diese Sprungnummer ein, weil ich habe noch ein Video, wie damals wir sind in das neue Büro gezogen und aus irgendeinem Grund war auf dem Gang, weil immer liegen irgendwelche Requisiten rum in Produktionsfirmen und da war diese Teller, wo unten diese Sprungfehler dran ist. Moment. Und da ist halt einer der Handwerker, ich gucke so nach rechts und da sollte noch so eine Tür eingesetzt werden, das heißt wir konnten nach rechts gucken auf den Gang und da ist einer der Handwerker auf diesem Sprungding vorbeigehüpft. Und man denkt sich, wow, warum hat man das nicht häufiger? Warum haben Leute diese Sprunggeräte nicht? Sprungtechnologie wird nicht adäquat verwendet, glaube ich. Man könnte ein ganzes Auto daraus bauen, vielleicht ist das irgendwann mal nötig. Ich bin nie gern gesprungen als Kind. Vielleicht lag es am Übergewicht, kann auch gut sein, aber alles was mit Springen zu tun. Ich machte so möglichst nah am Boden einfach so. Ich habe auch bei meinem Cityroller immer den Lenker ganz nach unten gemacht und wirklich so den einfach, dass ich mache, einfach so schwer. Aber auch weniger Windwiderstand. Aber auch einfach so, Schwerk so, einfach Schwerkraft ist mein Freund, einfach so, ich gebe dem einfach nach und bin einfach ganz klein.
Aber apropos Springen, ich habe heute diesen irrationalen Gedanken gehabt, ich bin einfach Bahn gefahren und habe kurz an den neuen Predator-Film gedacht.
Und ich dachte mir, Predator, halt dieser super gruselige Typ, der an den Leuten jagt, das im Jump House.
Kennt ihr diese Jump Häuser, wo so ganz viele Trampoline sind und so und angenommen der, und das gibt es ja am Ende, gibt es ja viele und so und die jagen Menschen über der Welt und dann ist der aber in diesem Jump House und alle Leute haben Angst vor dem und fliehen und weil sie schneller sind, würden sie natürlich nicht rennen, sondern sie würden die Trampoline benutzen, um von einem Ort zum anderen zu kommen. Das heißt, es wäre wahnsinnig lustig, finde ich, die Vorstellung, dass da irgendwie,
oder Zombie oder irgendwie
Snakes im Jump House. Aber sind die
nicht sogar unsichtbar, die Predator?
Dann wäre der Vorteil, man würde ja
sehen das Trampolin, wo
er abbauen ist und man sagt, ah, da ist er.
Kein Problem, Leute,
er ist noch weit weg. Aber Leute sind glücklich
auf Trampolin. Deswegen,
ich finde es einfach lustig, wenn Leute schreiend vor jemandem, vor einer tödlichen Gefahr auf einem Trampolin da weghüpfen würden. Was für Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen mache da so, also wenn ich sterbe, dann so. Ja, direkt, du kannst es nach unten gucken, durch das Netz und hast das Meer gesehen und konntest springen und es war großartig. war toll. Aber auch da mit dem schneller, ist man schneller springend oder laufend, ist halt auch immer die Frage in mittelhohem Wasser. So, wenn das Wasser bis hier ist, ungefähr so bis Brusthöhe, ab wann switcht man von Schwimmen zu laufen? Weil du willst nicht der sein, der dann irgendwie noch schwimmt und dann irgendwie alles dir deinen Bauch aufreißt, du willst aber auch nicht der sein, der im tiefen Wasser dann langsam läuft, während alle an dir vorbeiziehen. Du musst den genaueren Moment treffen, aber es ist nicht leicht, weil du läufst dann wieder auf den Strand und es gibt nichts Uncooleres, als dann der zu sein, weil Strandaufstieg ist ja das Wichtigste, alle gucken dich an, weil sie sich denken, wow, so viele Blutigel an einem Körper, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Blutigel, Blutegel, oder Seegel, jetzt kommen wir nicht mit Egel. Ich habe mich in den maritimen Gefilden ein bisschen eingelegt. Kommen wir nicht mit Egel, Egel ist der Grösste, was ist ein Egel? Die sehen aus wie Igel und essen Blut und sind Blutegel, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, das ist Quatsch. Ich habe mir die Namen nicht ausgedacht. Ich akzeptiere das nicht. So, ich brauche beide Hände jetzt. Wofür? Was hast du vor? Das ist eine Entspannung. Was hast du vor? Du bist klatschen. Einfach entspannen ein bisschen, das war mir zu krass. Das machen oft Musiker, um dann Dini zu machen. Ja, genau. Und die haben schon wirklich reflexartig mitgemacht. It's hard not life. Nee, komm. Funktioniert das? Das haltet ihr eh nicht durch. Und es gibt dann immer so eine traurige Gestalt, die das dann noch ganz, ganz lange durchmacht. Während Lenny Kravitz schon wieder gegangen ist, bei Wetten, dass zu seinem Flugzeug musste. Und dann schon weg ist. Auch der, der als erstes aufsteht bei Standing Ovations. Immer dieser eine ballsy guy. Ich denke immer, wenn ich aufstehe, kann hinter mir niemand mehr gucken. Also stehe ich immer erst dann auch, wenn der vor mir aufsteht. Aber ich habe nicht die Eier, direkt aufzustehen. Wenn mich was gut fand, würde ich nicht aufstehen. Ich würde klatschen. Es gibt auch die Leute, die kategorisch sitzen bleiben, die einfach sagen, wenn alle aufstehen, ne, ich nicht. Man sieht sie ja auch nicht. Man sieht sie nicht. Das stimmt. Das ist gut für die Leute auf der Bühne, die sind nur die Leute, die sie cool finden. Das ist wie Twitter. Du kannst die Leute blocken quasi. Die Leute blocken sich selbst. Das stimmt. Guck mal, ich mag es manchmal, dass wir ganz liebe Momente haben, wo man wirklich die Welt nochmal reflektiert. Ich finde das super. Es ist heute noch nicht passiert, dass jemandem Getränk runtergefallen ist. Das und Husten ist das häufigste, was vorkommt bei so vielen Menschen. Wenn so viele Menschen beisammenkommen, es fällt immer ein Getränk runter. Häufig fallen Getränke runter. Und wir hatten auch noch keine Bahnen-Anekdote. Wir haben noch nicht aus der Bahn erzählt. Wollt ihr eine geile Bahn-Anekdote? Wollt ihr eine geile Bahn-Anekdote? Ich hab's auch beim ersten Mal schon verstanden. Aber dann brauchst du das rote Mikrofon. Okay! Wow, das ist lauter. Wirklich? Ja. Okay. Deswegen habt ihr bei mir nicht gelacht. Also, schwierige Situationen kennt jeder. Ja, man sitzt am Tisch gegenüber von anderen Menschen. Und man schaut schaut diese Menschen an und manchmal sind es auch junge Frauen. So und dann ist es, man verbringt dann die Fahrt in einer mittelmässigen Ehe eigentlich so, manchmal finden sich die Augen, aber man redet nicht miteinander und man schaut zusammen aus dem Fenster. Nett, kann nett sein. So, junge Frau steht auf und unabhängig davon, wie ich das jetzt rausgefunden habe, ihre Hose ist offen. So, und jetzt, erst mal ist mir da der Gedanke gekommen, ach, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, das auch Frauen haben. Ich dachte immer so, ich habe jede Anekdote von Hosenstall offen immer nur bei Männern gehört und deswegen dachte ich mir wow, aber dann dachte ich mir Moment, ich habe nur gesehen, dass der Reißverschluss griff unten war. Ich habe nicht den Reißverschluss gesehen, ich habe nur den Reißverschluss griff gesehen, da dachte ich mir ah nee, bei Frauen ist ja alles andersrum, also machen die es andersrum auf. Der Kopf ist unten, die Beine oben ist alles anders. Es ist ja tatsächlich aus irgendeinem Grund so, dass bei Frauen die Kleidung andersrum geschichtet ist, was ich nie verstanden habe. Bei Frauen ist alles andersrum. Das klingt wie so eine süße Kindergarten. Bei Frauen ist alles andersrum. Und ich habe tatsächlich mal im Kostüm-Department nachgefragt, warum das so ist.
Und dann hat die Kostümbilderin mir gesagt, ja...
Du weißt, dass es Google gibt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Und dann hat die Kostümbilderin mir gesagt, ja, das hat historischen Ursprung,
und zwar, weil Frauen früher immer von anderen angezogen wurden.
Also so edle Frauen, die dann so große Kleider haben mit so ganz engen Korsetts,
die haben ja Hilfe gebraucht, und dann wurden die ja von anderen angezogen, deswegen musste alles anders sein. Aber dann dachte ich mir, naja, die wurden ja auch von Frauen angezogen, also von der Zofe. Ja, das Wort Zofe, da wollte ich auch noch mal. Ganz kurz, ich muss kurz ranten, ich hasse das Wort Zofe. Ich kann das Wort Zofe nicht haben. Was ist falsch mit Zofe? So ein selten benutztes Wort sollte nicht vier Buchstaben haben. I said it. That's, I said it. Aber das gleiche mit Amboss. Ja, dankeschön, dankeschön, da haben wir einen. Sehr gut. Das gleiche mit Amboss, es gibt nichts anderes als Amboss. Amboss ist Amboss. Warum hat Amboss fünf Buchstaben? Ja, nee, also Wörter sollten, man muss mal die guten Wörter freimachen. Spezielle Wörter, ja genau. Sowas wie Zofe. Oder ist das Amborstag? Ja. Ich bin doch dran. Aber Zofe könnte auch sowas wie ein Streit, könnte auch eine Zofe sein. So, ich hab ein bisschen Zofe mit dem. So, das funktioniert schon. Versuch das einfach mal im Sprachgebrauch mit einfließen zu lassen und guck, was passiert. Man weiß es nicht. Wo war ich? Zofen, Kleiden, edle Frauen, nein. So, und jetzt dachte ich mir, aha, okay, aber dann habe ich durch andere Informationen herausgefunden, dass es tatsächlich so ist. Und jetzt dachte ich mir, jetzt ist immer die Frage, sie ist auf dem Weg, sie steht auf und sie geht, wie kommuniziert man das jetzt? Ich will nicht durch den ganzen Zug brüllen, hey, ihre gleichaltrige Frau, man weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, deine ihre Hose ist offen. Deswegen dachte ich mir, mache ich es gestikulierend. Wie? Weil das ist jetzt pantomimisch ganz, ganz ungünstig darzustellen, sich selbst in den Schritt zu zeigen mit so einem, aber auch so. Man will ja auch sagen ist kein problem also grinst man so
schelmisch es ist so kann jedem mal passieren mit einem mit dem deuten aber dann das stelle
und das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nur für die hier in mannheim anwesenden interessant ich dachte mir, Moment mal. Oh ja, ich trage ein T-Shirt mit einer Hose drauf. Und ich dachte mir, Leute, jetzt haben wir es doch. Problematisch ist nur, dass der Schritt der Hose auf Brusthöhe ist. Ja, auch das. Und ich glaube, man achtet nicht sofort darauf, dass du eine Hose an hast. Ich dachte mir, okay, that's it. Ich habe eine Chance, ich gehe all in. Sie steht auf, packt ihre Sachen zusammen, wir haben noch mal kurz Blickkontakt, ich denke mir, ich gehe all in und mache den hier und sie so und geht.
Aber ist sie gegangen oder ist sie so klo gegangen? Sie ist gegangen, sie ist ausgestiegen. Diese Frau muss den Rest des Tages gedacht haben, dass kurz bevor sie gegangen ist, ich unbedingt noch mal darauf hinweisen wollte, ich habe eine Hose auf dem Tisch. Und sie und geht. Wirklich wie so ein Kind, das einem irgendwie so ein krakeliges Ding zeigt, so und geht. Wir haben einfach so komplett versagt. Sag mal, hast du 19,90 Euro ausgegeben? Sehr gut. Ja, mhm, toll. Oder so ein bisschen auch wie, ich habe die ganze Zeit gegenüber von dir gesessen. Ich? Ja, kann auch sein, dass sie einfach nur verstanden hat, ich, ja, hallo. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man es hätte machen sollen, aber es hat einfach überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Keine Ahnung. Das ist so toll, man weiß nicht, was man machen soll. Ich weiß es nicht. Würde es dir sagen können, theoretisch, aber das wäre auch zu einfach. Dann hätten wir gerade nicht so herzlich gelacht. Vor allem, ich denke immer so, oft versuche ich Probleme zu lösen, indem ich überlege, was würde ich in einem Film schreiben, wenn die Situation stattfindet. So, dass es interessant ist und cool. Und da denke ich mir immer so, man sollte vielleicht sowas machen wie, man tippt was auf seinem Handy und zeigt dann eher so das Handy mit einem Textdatei oder sowas und tut so, als würde man ein Selfie machen.
Von Bild von ihr drauf ist, von dem Schritt.
Fall schon mal.
Weil dann denkt sie entweder, what the fuck hat er das gerade erst gemacht?
Ne, ne, ne. Und ich habe noch die Röntgen-App auf meinem Handy. Also ich kann alles, ich kann alles kommunizieren.
Hat mal irgendwer, ich kenne niemanden, hat irgendwer diesen Jamba-Nacktscanner mal gehabt? Ging dann den Finger hoch, da hat sich was bewegt, aber es kann auch einfach niemanden sein. Das war kein Finger, Stefan, der da hochgegangen ist. Das war ein Mittelfinger. Nee, niemand, gar niemand? Hat das funktioniert? Natürlich nicht. Genau wie ich kurz dachte, weil dann gab es ja diese App, die man unterladen konnte, wo man reinpusten konnte und dann zeigt die einem an, wie ein Problem man hat. Das ist doch auch Quatsch, oder? Aber die haben ja auch Geld verdient, denn die ist ja im originalen App Store für 4,99 Euro zu kaufen. Sagt dann niemand, Leute, das Produkt, was ihr verkauft. Aber es kann sein, dass wir in den letzten 20 Jahren schon die Röntentechnologie hatten fürs Mobiltefon.
Es hat nur niemand geglaubt. Es hat niemand runtergeladen und es geht halt wirklich. Aber niemand hat es geglaubt. Weil mancher ist das so. Es gab auch mal eine Zeit lang, auch mal im internationalen App Store, aber auf Platz Nummer eins eine App, die hat einfach ein Klackgeräusch gemacht. Da hattest du so ein Plättchen auf dem Display und dann drückst du drauf und dann macht die Klupp, Klupp, Klupp. Das war die App. Das war die gesamte App. Das war alles. Und das hat jemand programmiert, der früher beim Militär war im Zweiten Weltkrieg, wo die Fallschirmjäger, die hatten, als sie im Feindesland abgesetzt wurden, hatten die auch so Knickergeräusche, dass wenn sie sich an jemanden anschleichen und sich überlegen, ist das jetzt ein deutscher Soldat oder nicht, dann machen sie Klick, klick, klick, klick und der amerikanische Soldat konnte zurückklicken, der deutsche dachte sich nur, wie bitte und konnte dann angegriffen werden. Und da dachte er so, um die Leute zusammenzubringen, macht er das auch und macht auch nur diesen Klicker und der war wahnsinnig erfolgreich. Und es gibt interessante Videos, die man sich angucken kann, wie der in ganz viele Talkshows eingeladen wurde.
Und dann die Interview-Ren...
Super nervig bestimmt, die ganze Zeit im Klick.
Und die Interview-Ren... Ah, okay, verstehe.
Und andere, die die App dann auf dem Handy haben, die kriegen dann eine Nachricht, wenn du im selben Raum bist.
Nee, nee, die macht nur...
Ah, okay, verstehe, und durch die Mikrofone der anderen Mikrofone wird das dann als Audiosignal übergenommen und dann merken die, dass du in der Nähe bist. Nee, also mach einfach nur Klick. Ah, und es gibt so eine Datei von Leuten, die es schon runtergeladen haben und nee, es macht nur Klick. Okay, wir kommen zum Wetter, einfach so, wo dieser arme Mann, der einfach nur so ein Klickgeräusch programmiert hat.
Aber es ist unglaublich.
Warum haben Sie diesen zwei Stunden Interviews-Gloch eingeplant?
Das stimmt, das merkt man dann nach fünf Minuten plötzlich.
Das war so ein Fehler.
Das trägt nicht.
War der falsche Gast.
Das trägt nicht, wie der Autor von der unendlichen Geschichte, wo man sich denkt, das trägt nicht.
Nee.
Es reicht eine Stunde Interview.
Es reicht.
Wir müssen nicht ein unendlich langes Interview vorbereiten.
Ach ja. Naja. Das war die Bahnanekdote. Das war die Bahnanekdote. Es gehört zu jedem Podcast. Es tut mir leid. Super gut. Es gehört zu jedem Podcast einfach dazu. Es tut mir leid. Wisst ihr, was auch so ein Podcast gehört? Eine Bandanekdote. Oh! Ich lade euch auch mal einen raus. Es war, man muss sich das vorstellen, das habe ich mir extra für die Natur überlegt. Er hat schon direkt den Freddie Mercury erhört. Das ist doch so. Aber das habe ich gerade in der Probe gemerkt, weil das Mikrofon ist zu hoch eingestellt, obviously, weil ich zu gross bin. Also das heißt, es ist die grösste Stufe, wenn ich es höher mache, geht das Oberteil raus. Heißt, es muss so sein. So, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt den
Freddie Mercury machen würde, geht das nicht, weil die Hebelwirkung zu gross ist und das ist lächerlich schwer alles.
Heißt, man zieht das so mit sich mit die ganze Zeit. Heißt, wenn Freddie Mercury so gross gewesen wäre wie ich, hätte das nicht
funktioniert. Er hätte diese ganzen coolen Moves nicht machen können. Das wäre einmal so ein...
Wir haben jetzt also auch die unendlich dringende Frage gelöst.
All we hear is radio-ga-ga!
Wir haben endlich die Frage geklärt, was ist stärker, Rock'n'Roll oder die Hebelwirkung?
Wir haben gefunden, die Hebelwirkung ist stärker als Rock'n'Roll.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wir haben damals bei Dortmunds Bester Band mitgemacht, richtig, Dortmunds Bester Band.
Also, aber ich verstehe, dankeschön, wir haben bis heute nicht genau verstanden, was dieser, ob das überhaupt dieser richtige, ob das legalerweise so genannt werden darf. Es waren mehr so alle Bands, die sich beworben haben, die davon mit diesen Aushang gelesen haben, der in einem Stadtteil hing. Trotzdem waren wir dann alle irgendwie da und wir sind komischerweise in die nächste Runde gekommen. Komischerweise sagt er bescheiden naja wir sind wir haben wir haben nicht die skills gehabt wir waren eine von fünf bands die sich beworben haben ich glaube sind viel in die nächste runde gekommen und dann muss man sagen ich wollte damals rebellieren weil wir haben wir haben punkrock gemacht trotzdem haben unsere eltern uns immer hingefahren unsere eltern unsere eltern wir hatten songs über keine ahnung eine songseile war immer schlampe ich brauch dich nicht wir wollten halt rebellieren, wir waren zwölf, dreizehn, unsere Eltern haben mitgesungen. So, du kannst nicht, du kannst nicht rebellieren in unserem Alter mehr, ist leider einfach nicht möglich. Schlampe, ich brauch dich. Ja, wir waren einfache Gemüter. Aber was reimt sich auf Nicht? Licht, Gicht. Ja, viel Spaß bei der zweiten Zeile. Gott, dein Herz hat nur diese eine gehabt. Das war der ganze Song. Ungefähr. Wir waren ein bisschen einfacher. Und unsere Eltern haben mitgesungen. Und es war schön irgendwie. Und wir haben komischerweise die Runde basierte dann darauf am Ende. Der Gewinner wurde erkoren durch ganz normal Los. Nicht Los, sondern diese Boxen, wo man halt Voting verfahren. Wahl. Demokratie kann man sagen, Wahl, richtig. Man hat also den Namen der Band draufgeschrieben und man wurde dann ausgesucht und unsere Eltern waren alle dabei. Heißt, unser Publikum war voll. Das ganze Publikum bestand eigentlich nur aus unseren Eltern, was die Veranstalter nicht wussten. Und dann kamen noch ein paar Freunde dabei und so weiter und die anderen Bands haben halt nur, haben halt härtere Songs gemacht und da wollten halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Eltern nicht mitsingen und so einen Scheiss.
Jedenfalls haben die es nicht geschafft und man hat gemerkt, der Veranstaltete, die mochten uns nicht so richtig.
Da kam es zu so einer komischen Der-Pate-Situation, wo wir kurz, ich bin irgendwie hoch aufs Klo und dann war da einer der Veranstalter, einer der Juroren.
Hoch aufs Klo.
Oben war das Klo. So, und ich bin hochgelaufen und dann kam es zu so einer Situation, wie er mit der anderen Band gesprochen hat und gesagt hat so, ja, ja, wir machen das schon.
Hat mich dann gesehen irgendwie in der Tür, hat dann die Tür so langsam zugemacht. Richtig, der Pate. Und ich wusste, wir haben keine Chance, leider, wir haben keine Chance. Er hat auch immer unseren Namen falsch ausgesprochen, wie hies denn damals, Expect, aber er hat immer, hier sind Accept gesagt beim ersten Mal, beim zweiten hier ist The Excerpt, beim dritten hier sind Green, der jetzt verkankt so ein bisschen und hat uns so ein bisschen abfacken wollen. Und am Ende des Tages haben wir halt einfach die meisten Stimmen bekommen und haben trotzdem gewonnen. Und dann sind wir, dann haben wir ein Studio, das wollte ich eigentlich nur sagen, wir haben dort um das beste Band gewonnen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, don't, don't, don't, don't. Wir haben dann nämlich einen Studioaufenthalt geschenkt bekommen, einen Tonstudioaufenthalt. Und ich, also man muss sagen, ich habe schon an dem ganzen Wettbewerb so gedacht, das wird bestimmt nicht so toll. Die schenken uns jetzt bestimmt kein gutes Studio. Wir kamen dann da an und es war die furchtbarste Stimmung in einem Haus, in dem ich jemals war. Es war furchtbar, weil die Katze weg war, weg von dem Tonstudio-Besitzer. Und es war einfach furchtbare Stimmung. Und wir haben halt unsere Songs halt da aufgenommen und haben so glücklich im Kreis gestanden und haben Schalalas aufgenommen, weil man musste auch so Backing-Tracks und dann Schalalala. Und dann war halt einfach dieser Tonmischer, da war einfach saumßig traurig, weil seine Katze halt weggelaufen war.
Das war die Situation ungefähr.
Und dann kam es halt irgendwann zu dem Punkt, wo wir dann irgendwann wieder einen Backing-Track aufgenommen haben.
Wir standen wieder im Kreis und haben Schalalalas eingesungen und plötzlich ging die Tür auf.
Wir standen da glücklich und er hat seine tote Katze auf den Händen in den Raum getragen.
Und wir standen da Schalalal fuck? Das war unsere Bandzeit. So kann man sich das vorstellen. Aber das war echter Rock'n'Roll, muss man mal sagen. Das war echt Rock'n'Roll. Ich habe mich auch immer gefragt, hat der Typ, der Veranstalter, die Katze umgefahren? War er schuld? Ich fand, das war so seltsam, diese ganze Situation. Oder ihr habt ihr die katze umgefahren beim anfahren ja das wäre das für eine gute pointe gewesen aber das echte leben deswegen manchmal schreibt das echte leben keine guten pointen aber hätte teilweise auch merken können dass es kein wirklich gutes studio war er hat dann irgendwann gesagt weil wir das schlagzeug aufnehmen wollen er hat gesagt ja wir haben drei mikros und wir haben aber mehr als drei Trommeln, muss man da nicht mehr Mikros dran machen, soll es überhaupt im Tonstudio nicht mehr als drei Mikros geben? Und er hat gesagt, nee, nee, nee, das machen heute alle so. Die Beatsteaks nehmen auch nur mit drei Mikros auf. Und da hätte man schon theoretisch drauf kommen können, ah, okay, das ist ja alles nicht so seriös, wie sterben Katzen in diesem Tonstudio. Okay, die Beatstakes. Wir sind die beste Band Dortmunds. Sorry. Okay, wir sind mit mehr als drei Mikros auf. Eins nach dem anderen. Vermisst du es manchmal? Ja, so ein bisschen, natürlich. Aber da kann man natürlich nicht vor so tollem Publikum spielen wie hier in Mannheim. Sind da mittlerweile noch Leute gekommen, die zu spätät kommen konnten die zu spät kommen wollten nein ich weiß auch nicht was ich antworten würde ich jetzt gesagt ja die person ist meist man auch nicht immer genau stell dir vor man kommt hier hin um zu häkeln und dann wird man aufgefordert zu häkeln ja das stimmt ist jemand zu spät gekommen und dann traut man sich auch nicht mehr, man will ja was Verbotenes tun. Das ist wirklich das Schlimmste, was passieren kann. Ja, das ist ja vernünftig. Hat jemand Fragen? Ich habe eine Frage. Ja. Was haben Menschen früher so gemacht? Das freut mich auch häufig. Also zum Beispiel, ich spiele Rollenspiele, muss ich dazu sagen, und man versucht sich da immer so in das Mindset von einem Menschen hineinzuversetzen, der im Mittelalter gelebt hat.
Und man hat ja immer so Angewohnheiten, die man so als Mensch immer hat, die man aber schwer abstellen kann. Zum Beispiel, wenn man eine Person, wenn die da so ist an der Schmiede und da die goldene Rüstung des Expekte schmiedet. Und man geht dann in den Söhne und sagt dann so, hey, und dann frage ich mich immer, hat man das im Mittelalter auch so gemacht? Gab es im Mittelalter auch, hey, weil hey ist hey an sich schon was Englisches oder gibt es hey dann als Altdeutsch oder heyer oder hasser oder oder was hat man gesagt aber sorry hat man gesagt sorry hey hey man weiß es einfach nicht genau ist hey ist das schon schon schon neudeutsch oder ist das was hat man gegen sonnenbrand gemacht ich habe keine ahnung ich weiß noch dass ich mal in kurzsichtigkeit ich war mal auf einem larp das ist das wo man dann sich so sachen anzieht und, ja. Und da habe ich auch massiven Sonnenbrand bekommen, weil ich natürlich keine Sonnencreme mitgenommen habe, weil ich natürlich dachte, wir gehen jetzt ins Mittelalter, ich brauche mein heiliges Schwert, Vollschaden plus drei, aber ich brauche keine Sonnencreme natürlich. Und waren dann da und dachten uns so, ja okay, wir sind jetzt richtig kaputt, wir haben uns in die Haut, das war am höchsten Sommer, uns die Haut abgeflattert und dann bin ich komplett rot und dann denkst du einfach, ich kann die Rolle nicht brechen, ich darf die Rolle nicht brechen, ich kann jetzt hier sagen, oh, edler Krieger, eure Fähigkeit mit dem Stahle sitzt wohl behende, habt ihr Sonnencreme vielleicht nebenbei, sorry, ich brauche sie, ihr seht ja was. Und ich habe Bock auf Skittles. Hat jemand Skittles? Es war wirklich schrecklich. Und irgendwann haben wir dann auch einfach aufgegeben und lagen einfach im Gras.
Und bei so Laabs ist es oft, dass man da nicht einfach irgendwas macht, sondern dass da was passiert. Da ist eine Geschichte. Also da wird dann irgendein Kind entführt und dann greifen die Orks an und bla bla bla und so. Und dann muss man als Spieler immer gucken, wo ist der Plot. So, weil man kann ja vielleicht auch nicht zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort sein. Und denkt sich dann, muss ich jetzt am Brunnen sein? Und dann, oh, ich habe gehört, da gibt es irgendwas im Wald und dann geht man weit. Und dann sind immer ganz viele Leute zu uns hergerannt, weil sie dachten, wir wären tot und wären erschlagen worden. Und das wäre der Plot. Und rennen zu uns und geht es euch gut, Edler Krieger? Und wir sind ja, alles gut. Und dann sind sie okay, dann gehen wir wieder zum Brunnen. Haben sie okay gesagt? Ich weiß nicht, ob sie okay gesagt hat. okay gesagt hat in ordnung okidoki man weiss es auch nicht genau vielleicht er war im falschen lab er wollte zum cowboy haben westworld artig wir hatten wahnsinnig wenig platz für unser lab es war schon wirklich man hatte so drei zelte zwischen dem man umhergehen konnte und es hätte auch schon sein können dass man das direkt daneben sohn so ein west Western-Lab ist und man sich dann über den Weg läuft. Das finde ich schon sehr lustig. Und man sich irgendwann verbündet gegen die Orks so, wir brauchen noch Leute, howdy! Ja, vor allem, ich habe neulich mit einem Kollegen gesprochen, da war irgendwie so ein Mittelalterfestival in der Nähe von Köln. Da hat er gesagt, die meisten Leute haben NASA-Shirts getragen. Man muss sagen, NASA-Shirts sind gerade irgendwie ein großes Ding. Ja, warum eigentlich? Und auch so ein Nerd-Ding. Aber wenn ihr Nerd seid und so ein Lab geht, dann zieht doch vielleicht einfach irgendwas anderes an. Aber wenn ich jetzt so ein NASA-Shirt haben wollen würde, wo kriege ich das denn? Das ist eine gute Frage. Muss man das nicht irgendwie bestellen oder so? Ja, ich glaube, Amazon. Ich habe damals beim Lab auch, da lag ich dann auf so einem Fell und wollte schlafen, konnte überhaupt nicht schlafen, weil ich mir dachte, warum muss ich hier auf Fell liegen? War das mal ein Tier? Worauf liege ich hier eigentlich? Haben Menschen wirklich so geschlafen? Die meisten Fälle waren mal ein Tier. Naja, es gibt ja auch irgendwie so Kunstfälle. Ich hatte immer ein riesiges Tigerfell als Kind und habe irgendwann mal erfahren, dass es gar kein echter Tiger ist. Und wenn ich euch ein Bild davon zeigen würde, es ist sehr offensichtlich, dass das keine... Weil so Strassen drauf sind und so kleine Häuser. Dass das kein echter Tiger ist. Aber ich habe eine Stauballergie und dieses Tigerfell war immer voller Staub, also massiv voller Staub. Ich weiß nicht, was Tiger richtig oder falsch machen, dass sie einfach sich so anstauben. Und ich habe den ganzen Tag geniess und geniess nur wegen diesem scheiß Tigerfell. Aber ich dachte mir, ich kann das nicht wegwerfen, da ist ein Tiger dafür gestorben, das kann ich nicht machen. Fuck! Ich muss, das kann ich nicht machen. Ein Tigerallergie gestorben, gegen Hausstaub. Dammit. Eines von beiden, kann ich auch zum Arzt sagen. Ich niese bei Tigern und bei Staub. Und ich glaube, ich bin doch gegen Birke oder Buche oder irgendwie sowas, bin ich auch noch mal allergisch. Beides möglich. Ich weiß ja auch nicht genau, wie die aussieht. Ich war auch gegen sehr viel allergisch. Es gab auch ein paar Sachen, wo ich dann einfach so, also Pfadfinder war ein dunkles Kapitel, wo ich mich an viel nicht mehr erinnern kann, wegen Allergie, wo ich dann einfach irgendwann so bewusstlos in der Ecke lag, weil ich durch so ein Roggenfeld gelaufen bin, wie man es aus Filmen kennt, dass man so durchs Roggenfeld läuft. Keine gute Idee, sollte man nicht machen, wenn man gegen Roggen allergisch ist, obviously. Aber dann lag man wirklich so am Lagerfeuer abends und Leute haben gesagt ach, Stefan ist müde. Nee, Stefan ist fast tot. Stefan ist durch Roggen gelaufen. Er ist allergisch gegen Knoten. Ja, muss auch... Dammit. Was macht er bei den Pfadfindern? Ja, was macht man bei den Pfadfindern? Das ist auch meine Frage. Ich dachte, da lernt man einfach nur Knoten, um dann Serienmörder zu werden. Ich habe viele Knoten. Direkt. Wozu braucht man Knoten? Ja, wenn man das Kind gefangen hat, damit man es vernünftig was beibringen kann. Einfach dir so. So kannst du auch mal Serienmörder werden. Ja, kann man. Ich weiß nicht. Knoten? Nee, fand ich nie gut. Ich habe alles mitgemacht. Ich habe wirklich Fahrtfinder, Messdiener, alles mitgemacht. Ich glaube, der Tiefpunkt meiner Kindheit war, mit so einer Bügelzahnspange mit den Messdienern in einen Freizeitpark ohne Achterbahn zu fahren. In diese Uncoolen, in diese wirklich, wirklich Uncoolen, das war, was hier ist nochmal, das ist Kernwasser Wunderland. Und zwar war da früher, das gibt es wirklich. Kernwasser? So wie ich von einem Atomkraftwerk. Ja, richtig. Früher ist es ein stillgelebtes Atomkraftwerk. Mittlerweile kann man, ist da, werden dann so Karus so ein bisschen shady, alles sieht so ein bisschen aus wie man sich so Tschernobyl vorstellt, so verlassen. Es sind auch nicht viele Leute da, ist alles ein bisschen runtergekommen und es gibt auch keine Achterbahn, Gott sei Dank, weil Leute sterben werden, wenn sie es benutzen würden, aber irgendwie so Streichelzoo und sowas und halt in diesem alten Kernkühl, whatever, da konnte man auch reingehen. Wasser? Nein, und da war, nein, das wurde alles abgelassen und jetzt ist ein Karussell drin. Das war randvoll mit Wasser? Nein. Ich stelle es mir randvoll mit Wasser vor. Okay, aber jedenfalls gab es dann das, ich weiss nicht mehr, wie es aussah, aber es gab das Maskottchen Kerni. Oh Gott, er war ein dicker Russe.
Kerni war ein dicker Russe, mit zwei Köpfen wahrscheinlich, man weiß es nicht genau.
Rückblickend muss man da mal checken, ob da alles so gut gelaufen ist, ob die auch wirklich alles stillgelegt haben.
Das war schon weird, das war ein bisschen Geister, Geister Freizeitpark.
Das Kern macht's ja Wunderland.
Ich war tatsächlich als Kind in einem komischen Lager, das ich mir nicht erklären konnte. Rückblickend denke ich mir immer, diese Lager sind dafür da, um die Kinder loszuwerden, damit die Eltern ein bisschen Dark Souls spielen können oder sowas. Und dann müssen die Kinder weg und dann sagt man so, ah, du willst doch mal Physiker werden, geh doch mal ins Kernwasser. Aber das Lager, bei dem ich war, das war so zehn Minuten von meinem Haus entfernt. Und ich habe da letztens noch mal so ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht, was das für ein Lager war und dachte mir, das muss ein Abnehmlager gewesen sein. Ich kann es mir nicht anders erklären. Und das ist ja so, so wir gehen jetzt ins Disneyland, da wird man beschnitten oder so. Man muss ja als Kind, als Kind muss man ja alles so ein bisschen verkaufen, dass man einfach nicht weiß, was jetzt kommt. Und seitdem bist du dünn und heterosexuell. Das stimmt. Und dann war ich da so, jetzt lauft noch mal ums Haus, schnell, und warum, warum. Und dann haben wir da so, und dann hat jeder so ein Solarpaneel bekommen, und dann konnte man da so einen Hubschrauber dran bauen an dieses Solarpanel.
Aber mir erinnert mich auch nicht.
Hubschrauber sind cool. Weg mit der Barbie-Puppe.
Hubschrauber sind cool.
Will noch jemand einen Salat oder einen Tee? Nee, ich weiß es hier genau. Ich kann mir nicht mehr erklären, was das war.
Flo und die Skittles. Flo und die gibt mir die Skittles. Flonti, gib mir die Skittles.
Und du hast zwei Punkte jetzt.
So wie wenn es ein Weight Watchers Camp war mit Kindern.
Wo man rechnen lernt und abnehmen lernt.
Das stimmt.
Das kann sein.
Aber ich habe weder rechnen gelernt noch abgenommen,
weil ich auf dem Nachhauseweg am Aldi vorbeigekommen bin.
Schön Colorado!
Könnt ihr so viel Mühe geben, wie ihr wollt. Ich gebe mit dem Colorado ins Bett. Als Kind wird man zu jeden Sachen geschenkt. That's it. Das stimmt, aber muss man seine Kinder zu Hobbys zwingen eigentlich. Ich sehe oft Menschen, die haben keine Hobbys und ich weiß nicht, ob das ein so glückliches Leben ist, weil es gibt Leute, die spielen World of Warcraft, die können ihr ganzes fucking Leben World of Warcraft spielen, die sagen, du bist arbeitslos und sagen yes und spielen einfach World of Warcraft und haben einfach Zeit oder sagst du, ich mach Schluss mit dir und sagst yes, okay, schön mal wieder raven gehen. Aber so Leute wie du, die keine Hobbys haben, deswegen denke ich mir, ist es nicht, also die Eltern zwingen einen ja oft zu so Sachen, so du musst jetzt Geige spielen oder du musst jetzt das Cembalo spielen oder sowas. Muss man das nicht eigentlich machen, seine Kinder zu Hobbys zwingen? Ja, gute Frage, ich glaube schon. Also Kinder haben ja von sich aus keine Interessen. Kinder sagen ja jetzt nicht, wow, ich habe richtig Bock, jetzt klassische Lieder auf der Gitarre zu spielen, meine rechten Fingernägel länger wachsen zu lassen, damit ich besser Gitarre spielen zu können, meine linken so, dass es wehtut kurz, damit ich schön Gavotte in A-Moll spielen kann. Das passiert nicht. Aber es hilft halt schon mal, um so ein bisschen über den Tellerrand hinauszugucken. Danach entdeckt man ja vielleicht, dass AC DC eine gute Band ist und man Bock hat, das zu spielen. Ja, das stimmt. Ich musste ja diese ganzen klassischen Lieder spielen, weil mein Gitarrenlehrer keine Lust mehr hatte auf ACDC, weil alle Kinder ACDC spielen wollten. Und er sagte, nee, wir machen jetzt mehr schön Fernando Caroli. Und du so, ich hab nämlich das Alte erreicht, wo ich ernsthaft erwachsene Menschen widerspreche. Von daher, von mir aus. Aber mein, unfassbar, mein Gitarrenlehrer, habe ich vielleicht auch schon mal gezählt, wenn nicht, würde es mich sehr wundern. Mein Gitarrenlehrer, dem hat ein Finger gefehlt.
Und jetzt alle?
Nein.
Und zwar, mein Gitarrenlehrer hat ein Finger gefehlt, unfassbarerweise, und zwar der einzige Finger, den man nicht zum Gitarrespielen braucht.
Den Daumen.
Den linken Daumen.
Und zwar den rechten kleinen Finger.
Hä?
Den rechten kleinen Finger.
Also bei meinem G.
Ja, das ist aber die linke Hand, Stefan.
Völlig richtig.
Das ist völlig richtig.
Ja, den linken kleinen Finger braucht man häufig.
Oh, sehr beliebt an der Ostseite.
Fingergag-Enthusiasten auf der Seite, hallo.
Danke, schön.
Und genau den hat der verloren.
Wo ich mir auch denke, das ist auch die einzige Situation, wo du nach einem irgendwie so ein China-Böller in der Hand explodiert aufguckst und denkst, yes, yes, ein Zählen getroffen, genau. Ich muss nicht meine Musikschule zumachen. Nice, sehr schön. Und einmal hat meine Mitschülerin, die haben immer vor der Tür gewartet und ich habe immer in der Lobby gewartet, weil ich nichts mit denen zu tun haben wollte. Und die kam dann immer raus, um mich zu holen. Und einmal kam die so raus, so wie ich nach dem dritten Jahr, wo wir Gitarre gelernt haben, und sie mir so, ist ja schon mal aufgefallen, dass dem ein Finger fehlt. Und geht wieder. Und dann war ich so, wow, das ist der Threshold an Nachrichten, den es braucht, um es dem unbeliebten Kind zu sagen. Das ist wirklich, genau das muss überschritten werden. Dann sage ich es auch Florentin, der gerade das klassische Magazin liest, das da ausgelegt ist. Wo hast du bei diesen Vorspielabenden gespielt? Warst du eher ganz hinten oder warst du das Vorprogramm? Nee, ich war immer, das ja wirklich fies. Die Besten sind immer hinten. Die Besten sind immer hinten, die Schlechten sind am Anfang und die Eltern müssen sich durcharbeiten und es ist schrecklich, um am Anfang zu spielen. Aber ich habe irgendwann auch immer alleine gespielt und wir haben auch einmal zu dritt im Freien gespielt, das war ich nicht noch, dümm Idee aller Zeiten, und es gibt ja kein leiseres Instrument als
vor allem neben dem Flugplatz,
es gibt kein leiseres Instrument als
klassische Gitarre von
sechsjährigen Fingern gespielt.
Keine Reaktion aus der Fingerecke, doch da sind sie!
Da sind sie,
die kann man sich verlassen.
Und wirklich, die haben ja gar keine Kraft in den Händen,
also Kinder, die haben ja keine Kraft in den Händen, denen kannst du alles aus der Hand nehmen, was du willst. Die haben keine Kraft. Wirklich, egal was ein Kind in der Hand hat, du kannst es einfach nehmen. Ausser Babys, ausser Babys, die haben extreme Kraft. Im Vergleich? Ja, wie so ein Anaconda können sie deinen Zeigefinger zerquetschen, aber diese Macht verlieren sie aber irgendwann. Und du meinst, dann geht es wieder in so ein Tal und dann sind Kinder einfach so, ach das ist dein Bounty?
Wir können nichts dagegen tun.
Was braucht gerade ein Flashback aus deinem Abnehmencamp, oder?
Ups.
Wir waren wahnsinnig leise und der Wind hat gebraust und irgendwann hat mitten im Stück der Gitarren, der da reingelufen, Ich glaube, es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,. Und dann wird's automatisch Highway to Hell, muss man sagen. Da wird auch Francesco Avotti, wird dann automatisch Highway to Hell. Aber irgendwann, sorry, meine ganze ganze Fettding sind meine ganzen Kindheitserinnerungen wieder hochgekommen. Meine Gitarrenlehrer hat irgendwann auch ein Konzert gegeben, das wir auch anschauen konnten. Und da muss man auch sagen, ist die Gitarre als Instrument so gut, wenn sie solche Hilfe braucht. Und zwar hatte der in dem Schaft, also der Schaft der Gitarre, Ende den Korpus und dann gibt es ja so einen 90-Gran-Winkel zwischen Korpus und Schaft. Und in diesem Winkel hatte er so einen richtig handfaustgrossen Batzen Vaseline in der Gitarre. Und er hat immer, während er gespielt hat, seine Finger ganz schnell mit Vaseline benetzt, weil er wollte nicht, dass die Saiten einen so ein Fiehgeräusch erzeugen, wenn man daran gleitet, was ja viele auch, also punkige Rock'n'Roller gerne mal nutzen. Aber als klassischer Gitarist wirst du das auf gar keinen Fall und da musste ich mich fast übergeben, da dachte ich mir einfach so hat man sich das nicht vorgestellt. So hat man sich das nicht vorgestellt. So Strubelpeter, lange Fingernägel, dann diese Vaseline, dann oft dieser Pferdeschwanz, der auch nicht hilft. Man ist wirklich halb Mensch, halb Cyborg, du bist halt völlig überrasst. Dann diese Fussbank, die auch noch kommt, wo man sagt, Leute, es muss alles so sein. Wo es immer war, so auf jeder Party, auf der neunklässler Schulparty, auf die jemand gehen musste, deswegen war ich auch da.
Und das heißt dann so, wie du kannst Gitarre spielen, spiel doch mal was und ich nur so, ich hab meinen Fussschemel nicht dabei.
Weder Baseline noch Fussbänkchen dabei.
Carina dachte sich so, okay, ich spiel drei Lieder und ich bin dein, aber ich hatte nicht den Fussschemel.
Ohne Fussbank, ohne dich. Das ging nicht. Ich hatte meinen eigenen, ich hatte meinen eigenen, immer dabei, mit meinem Gitarrenfach. Und es gab mal ein Kind, das hat... Aber wo man gut erzählen kann, man kann gute Anekdoten erzählen, wenn man diese Fussbank hat, das ist wie, um dann dich irgendwann so hinstellen. Ach, deswegen machen die das hier mit denen, dass man so den Nee, das ist cool. Wenn man den Fussschirm hat. Das ist cool, Fussbänken ist nicht cool. Das ist zu cool. Einmal hat auch ein Kind, und wir reden hier wirklich von sieben, acht, neun Jahre alten Kindern, also wirklich kleinen, keine Kraft in den Händen, und hat, als das Kind auf den Gitarrennurig gewartet hat, man muss dann immer so auf den Flur warten, dann kam man rein, hat es seine Gitarre zerstört. Hat den Schaft abgebrochen und dann so, okay, ja, jetzt Klein Harald, kommst du und dann die Gitarre kaputt gemacht und wirklich so, das ist Rock'n'Roll, neunjähriges Wein des Kindes, die eine zerbrochene Gitarre in der Hand hat, so eine Bärchen-Gitarre, wo einfach überall so Bärchen und Blümchen, die einfach zerstört ist und dann einfach so der Lehrer auch so, ja, dann kannst du jetzt nach Hause gehen. Weil was soll noch passieren? Und alle anderen Kinder so, das müssen wir machen, um nach Hause zu leben. Ja genau, und so ist Rock'n'Roll entstanden. Aber es ist wirklich so, dann der Unterricht, sitzt man dann noch da und oder geht man dann nach Hause? Das Problem ist mal, ich wollte auch mal eine Gitarre kaputt machen, aber es ist halt echt nicht einfach. Also das ist einfach. Akustikgitarren sind einfach kaputt zu machen, aber so ein Fender-Nachbau oder sowas, diese krassen, grossen E-Gitarren, die kriegst du mit 13, wenn du auf der Bühne stehst und Green Day nachmachst, nicht kaputt. Und dann nimmst du die halt und deine Bandkollegen haben auch aufgehört zu spielen, dann stehst du da und machst sie kaputt und es passiert halt einfach gar nichts. Gar nichts. Und dann guckst du ins Publikum und alle warten halt auf den nächsten Ecken und denken, was macht der da gerade? Deine Eltern sind da so, noch mal ein bisschen härter, Schatz. Härter, Schatz. Papa macht stolz ein Foto. Ist nicht so schlimm, wenn du es nicht schaffst. Machen wir zu Hause. Halt mal höher, halt mal höher ein bisschen. Oder dein Vater kommt auf die Bühne und hilft dir einfach. Ich komme darauf zurück, du kannst nicht rebellieren. In der heutigen Zeit kann ich mir sagen, die Gitarren sind zu gut gebaut und Eltern sind zu supportive. Das stimmt, ja. Es ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Ach Mannheim, wir nehmen uns langsam dem Ende. Ach, traurig. Aber das war der Auftakt? Der war die Ersten.
Die Ersten der zweiten Tour gibt es auch später noch umsonst als Podcast.
Und kleiner Hinweis, die ganze Aufnahme gibt es später noch umsonst als Podcast.
Könnt ihr euch runterladen?
Aber ihr habt 26 Euro rausgegeben dafür, dass ihr es eine Stunde eher hören konntet.
Ist das nicht mega geil?
Das war Mannheim!
Dankeschön.
Aber nicht nur das.
Ihr habt nicht nur dafür, 26 Euro rausgegeben, sondern wir freuen uns, euch neues Merch vorstellen zu dürfen. Ja, exklusiv für die Tour verkaufen wir jetzt das Podcast-Ufo-Tassen-Shirt. Manche haben es schon vielleicht bei Twitter gesehen, aber das könnt ihr wirklich kaufen. Und deswegen, wenn ihr Bock habt, euch das Motiv gefällt und ihr das Podcast-Ufo von außen tragen wollt, dann tut das gerne. Ihr könnt die Ersten sein, die dieses T-Shirt... Ey, ganz unironisch, ey, ohne Scheiss, vielen Dank, dass ihr gekommen
seid, ihr wusstet auch nicht, wie es wird, wir improvisieren die ganze Scheisse, also von daher
wusstet ihr nicht, dass es so wird, wie es wird und hätte ja auch noch, hätte noch besser sein
können, viel besser, hätte aber auch noch wesentlich schlechter sein können, von daher
vielen, vielen Dank Mannheim, danke, dass
das Podcast auch gehört. Und macht's gut, bis zum
nächsten Mal. Tschau!
Dankeschön! Vielen Dank.